[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
beef beef I'm Sean Evans coming at you
from Madison Square Park in New York
City the site of the annual Big Apple
barbecue block party a celebration that
draws some of the best pitmasters the
entire country for a barbecue showcase
unlike any other today we're going to
get a crash course in the regional
styles and leading the charge for us as
mad at do one of the most celebrated
meat maestro's in New York City and the
owner of pig Beach Brooklyn the weather
is beautiful
the smell is incredible let's go mix it
up so we stumbled across Matt on Madison
Avenue and it's so crazy here there's so
much going on
did you give us our plan of attack our
plan of attack is to eat to embrace to
see these iconic barbecue legends when
we got Chris Lilley we got John Wheeler
we got Billy Durney
these people are barbecue royalty
they're the best in the country at what
they do and it's really exciting to have
them all here in New York City for the
weekend all right well I'm ready to eat
you ready unit Mon man let's get it done
let's go man we're starting with Big
John Wheeler now John your reputation
precedes you a little bit because I
understand that if you're talking ribs
you got to talk to John or so this is
not John Wheeler Lord wheeler Tasha
champion in Memphis and when we go to
people to learn he's our first phone
call what makes the Memphis barbecue
company ribs special what makes special
is our time tips our dry rubs our
preparation we start with a honey
mustard glaze to put a dry rub on there
we smoked up about four and a half hours
we take them out put them in a cooler
and let them rest and if we come out put
it right on the open-faced grilled roll
with it and then just look at the smiles
on the faces and you know there's so
many different kinds of ribs what the
Memphis trip baby back ribs that's
derivative Memphis you know to Kansas to
anything out the spares or the cyclist
cooked
Texas has to be free ever heard the
saying about how the Hulk well it's the
highest mourn the ho right on top so
that's the best rib area people always
say with the rib that it should fall off
the bone is that true lots of bone is
overdone you should have a little tug
and come clean just like that so look at
the smoke in that rib the Sudbury's of
faintness that beautiful little soda can
come right off the bone so tender off
very sweet in the sauce and moist they
got that tacky outside that glaze like
these are not overcook these are not
dried the ribs delicious we have some
more stops to go but John thank you very
much well you can't talk about regional
barbecue was not talking about Texas and
you can't talk about Texas barbecue
without talking about Christmas
absolutely we have seen rivers near from
Salt Lake out of Texas you and it's
better than anybody else here they have
a lot of parties brisket is such a
staple of Texas barbecue I imagine that
it's a pretty crowded and competitive
marketplace how do you guys stand out
well we use our own dry rub 32 different
ingredients in it they make it with all
the fat on so all the moisture and all
the flavor goes into the risk the risk
is cut in two different pieces the top
part recalls neckl more of a marbled
gonna meet a leader cut is the loin si
ninety nine some people like put your
front mccain which one I like going I
like going I like a third part of the
Lloyd for in Firenze that's have a big
topic regarding that dude I've got the
most flavor profile out of ballpark
lovers must embark on this brisket you
said tonight are good deep dark color
and look at this two guys you see this
incredible smoke ring happening our
outside that natural pink hue that
occurs from the smoke interaction of the
meat you pull it apart
look at that off mouth in your mouth the
list
[Music]
Shawn Big Apple Rock party does not
occur on our third friend crystal five
times
Grand Champion Memphis invade ten times
first place shoulder Memphis MA I mean
this guy is a legend this is our 15th
year the Big Apple barbeque block party
1550 masters representing nine different
states and me representing the great
state of Alabama baby let's talk about
Alabama because you know you're a pulled
pork legend and when it comes to pulled
pork you hear about the Carolinas a lot
can you talk about the differences sure
in Carolina starting from the East Coast
you get into your whole hog Big Bob
Gibson barbecue started in 1925 and he
was cooking whole pork shoulders our
pork is it is as good as it's going to
get right off the pit why does your pork
win so often what do you think different
about it it's directly over our fire Oh
Kingsford Charcoal and hickory wood so
all mine the pork is dripping and
basting on it and it's also the fat is
rendering and dropping down into the
fold then you get a charged moisture it
gives us a little elevated flavor I'm
ready to try some award-winning pork
let's do it we've got a little sample
here take a look at that right there oh
my god there's nobody been in the
business Chris Lilley pork shoulder
thanks for having a product creators
absolutely
[Music]
Donna when she shoots my very good
friend barbecue brother Billy Duren in
brother he has some of the best barbecue
in all the great city you know it's
interesting to kind of end up here
because we met people from Tennessee and
Texas the North Carolina and Alabama can
you talk about New York's barbecue
culture a submerging place and then cold
puzzle some of my best friends are here
today Pat Martin from Nashville Sam
Jones from ADA North Carolina those guys
are kind of bound by tradition and their
tradition are to be cooking whole hogs
be cooking beef ribs or brisket and the
beauty from Matt Matt and I is that we
have no rules here where do you guys
draw inspiration committee was falling
in love with Texas part with you and
then just you know kind of bringing my
street kid from Brooklyn mentality to it
we're putting a multi-ethnic spin on it
to make in West Indies Vietnamese Korean
Italian Jewish and I pull from all those
things what does it mean to cook good
barbecue first of all I think you got to
cook on a clean fire and you got to
source the best products for me I think
people should use their local butchers
now barbecue takes a lot of time and you
really have to have that focus to be
with a cook I mean brisket beef ribs I
mean those are you know 15 hour cooks
and if you don't have that sort of time
commitment but that loves commitment you
know the barbecue is going to get away
from you so would love and focus would
probably some of the greatest things for
me of cooking good barbecue would say
baby I sure appreciate we managed to
come down you've got a pleasure how do
you feel about this a good day man thank
you thank you we had a class
[Music]
it's a vegetable and suppose we live
yeah we lawyer